what does the US Constitution mean to
you to me the Constitution means wisdom
the Constitution is unchanging the
Constitution means to me a covenant if
you're like many Americans you may not
realize how important the Constitution
is or the rights and liberties it
provides Hillsdale College America's
uniquely independent classical liberal
arts college is offering a free online
course Constitution 101 for a limited
time you actually have to study some
very fundamental things to learn the
meaning of america and the causes of its
constitution with over a half a million
already enrolled constitution 101 is
available free for a limited time
without the constitution and without a
knowledge of the constitution we don't
know what our liberties are how they're
secured or how to perpetuate them
americans are giving up their
constitutional rights every day and then
may not even know it so register today
online pursue truth defend Liberty don't
wait register for this free online
course today